a black schoolgirl was assaulted by
three white boys science shows red meat
is bad for you and men are paid less
than women for equal work the only
problem with all of those headlines is
that none of them are true we will
examine the latest hate hoax then some
science hoaxes and then a whole slew of
political hoaxes then Joe Biden's
corruption defense continues to crumble
with a new photo that just came out and
president Trump congratulate ska munis
China on 70 years of misery all that
more I'm Michel Knowles and this is the
Michel Noel's show
[Music]
oh this story had everything the media
wanted this you I'm sure you saw the
headlines it was about a school where
Mike Pence's wife works and a young
black girl was assaulted physically
assaulted by three white boys proving
America's racism proving that we haven't
done anything to better ourselves in
this country and had everything the
media wanted white on black racial
bigotry a cute little girl in a
Christian school not just any Christian
school but the one where Mike Pence's
wife works so the mainstream media ran
this story everywhere here is just a
little smattering of the breathless
reporting local news national news CNN I
don't know if CNN counts as national
news because three people watch it and
then it's just on in the airports but
nevertheless here is the media running
with this story police in Virginia are
investigating reports of an attack at a
school 12 year old Emory Allen says
three boys cornered her and cut off some
of her locks and here is here is how she
describes the incident the boys came up
to me and like they ambushed me
sort of like cage man and so they put
their hands over my mouth they've got my
hands behind my back and they just like
started cutting my hair and saying that
it was ugly the Emmanuel Christian
school reported the allegations to law
enforcement and said they have a
zero-tolerance policy on bullying and
abuse this is the same private school
where the wife of the vice president
Karen pence teaches two days a week the
office of the second lady has not
commented on the incident
school officials say that all the
students involved including Allen are
not attending classes during this
investigation the school says it is
quote deeply disturbed by the
allegations adding that Emanuel has a
zero-tolerance policy for bullying and
abuse Vice President Mike Pence's wife
Karen pence teaches art part-time at a
manual that's something that garnered
national attention earlier this year
when it was revealed that the school has
a policy banning gay students and
parents okay before we get into the
actual story itself let's just correct
the record on what they're saying about
this school they're saying it bans gays
students and parents that is not true it
enforces
is traditional Christian sexual ethics
so it said doesn't care if you're gay or
not gay but you're not allowed to commit
sex acts that are outside of traditional
Christian ethics I'm sure that they're
not exactly supportive of the hook-up
culture either or throuple x' or
threesomes or any of those things - just
a minor point on the bigger story cute
young girl says that she has been
viciously attacked by these boys there's
a racial angle it's pulling on the
heartstrings it's backing up the
mainstream media's biases so local TV
national TV every newspaper runs this
story and if it were just those stories
if it were just what you just heard I
could almost see it why the media are
biased they like to run stories that
confirm their biases they hate the
Pence's they hate Christianity they
think that America is hopelessly racist
they're convinced of it so I actually
sort of get why they would run it okay
not this isn't me completely knocking
the media for this but they didn't just
leave it at that they had to get more
and more sensational here's another
story on the same story from CNN
twelve-year-old sixth grader Amari Allen
is healing after she says three white
male classmates at Emmanuel Christian
school in Springfield Virginia targeted
and attacked her because of her hair
okay this is where the reporting becomes
really irresponsible also why is she
playing violin what on earth does that
have to do with the story why does it
begin that way either because they're
obviously constructing this narrative
this good studious girl she's even nicer
than she seemed on the first news clip
and now they're she's being victimized
by I don't know probably mini David
dukes or something like that and where
the reporting becomes irresponsible is
they don't have any evidence that the
story actually occurred and the wording
is important here so if they had said if
they had said twelve-year-old armory
allen says she is healing after she
alleges three boys pinned her down that
would be one thing that would be a news
story
they don't say that they say
twelve-year-old on Murray Allen is
healing is healing after she says and
then they go on that's a big difference
because it turns out that she isn't
healing because it turns out she was
never hurt in the first place because
the problem with the story is that it
never happened it wasn't true here's how
we know we'll get we'll get to how we
know in a second we'll get to what this
means for her culture and for the news
media but first I have to thank a new
sponsor we love these guys over at Rock
Auto so I've thought about this recently
because I was having a little car
trouble on a drive up to San Francisco
the car parts business doesn't make
sense anymore
the way that the car parts business
works you go to the shop and they never
have the part that you need I mean the
parts are so specialized now they don't
keep them in stock so then what do they
do they go on the internet and then they
mark it up a huge percentage and then
for some reason you pay these guys to
get you the auto parts you want skip
that yet get rid of that go to Rock Auto
comm Rock Auto is a family business
they've been serving auto parts online
for 20 years go to Rock Auto comm to
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers they have
everything they have engine control
modules brake parts tail lamps motor oil
new carpet they have parts that I don't
even know what they do because I don't
know a whole lot about car parts but
what I do know is I want to get the
cheapest deal that I can possibly find
for excellent quality parts cut out that
middleman not have to pay all of these
ridiculous markups whether it's your
classic or whether it's your daily
driver you can get everything you need
in a few easy clicks delivered directly
to your door I love these guys I think
they're they're a terrific company to
begin with just in terms of their
character and they provide a service
that is totally ahead of the curve they
are just great
even the web I love the website so much
because it's so simple somebody like me
I'm a millennial I don't know a whole
lot about my cars I just know I like
them to drive I like them to work and
they make it so simple for you the
rockauto.com catalog is unique very easy
to navigate you can see all the parts
quickly that are available for your
vehicle choose the brands specifications
and prices that you prefer I love these
guys great selection
laia bleah incredibly low prices all the
parts your car will ever need
rockauto.com go to rockauto.com right
now see all the parts available for your
car or truck and then this is the most
important part you need to write knowles
in there how did you hear about us box
so that they know that we sent you we
love these guys so please give us a
shout out over there you're gonna love
their products that is a rockauto.com
right knowles and how did you hear about
us section okay so that's the the
problem by the way i showed you a
smattering of the news stories about
this this was all over the place print
TV radio and the problem is the story
never happened the family now admitted
that it was a lie how did we find out it
was alive II as law-enforcement
officials investigated it here's the
girls original story quote one of the
boys put his hand over my mouth so I
wouldn't scream while they used scissors
on my hair they were all laughing
calling me ugly and saying I should
never have been born this is pretty
awful to hear about this that even that
forget even the racial aspect which is
what the media ran with just think about
the sex aspect you've got these three
boys doing this to this vulnerable girl
it sounds terrible then she goes on she
says they ran off laughing and I was
just sitting there I'm hurt that it
happened all I want to ask them is why I
mean sounds really bad the LA beast ran
this story breathlessly without checking
on one single fact now they're paying
for that today when the truth came out
her mother said it took two days for the
little girl to admit that the attack
happened except now we know that the
attack didn't happen so what's going on
here the twelve-year-old initially said
when she was asked by her mother why she
was missing parts of her hair she said
she was playing beauty salon with her
friend so she was you know playing a
game and I think a I guess the kids cut
each other's hair and then two days goes
by and then she changes her story and
said these kids held her down and and
tried to hurt her and threatened her you
do feel for the girl yeah I mean what
kind of situation made this girl make up
this story and accuse her classmates and
do all those terrible things could be
the case that you know the girl cut her
hair off with her friend or by herself
and then her she didn't want to get in
trouble
with her mother so she made up this
story about her classmates who knows
this is what the mother said though my
concern is how did they not see what was
taking place on the playground of all
year Karen pence the vice president's
wife works at the school there's
security and Secret Service anywhere
everywhere how did they not know right
this is the point in the story where
you've got to turn your faculties of
reason on and say hold on this has got
to be one of the most secure schools in
America nobody heard about this nobody
saw this happen
maybe something isn't right about the
story and the girl the the little girl
made a big issue she said they had
scissors they could have done anything
to me they could have done it so she's
saying they could have I don't know
stabbed or cut her or killed her she
went on I was afraid if I told the
teacher they wouldn't care what what
about this teacher makes you think she
wouldn't care if if kids were
threatening you with scissors and
cutting your hair doesn't hold up so the
police investigate that's good and the
girl's story fell apart why did she lie
wait I know maybe she didn't want to get
in trouble maybe she thought there would
be some sort of social reward for this
story maybe something else happened and
we just don't know and she just wanted
to do it I don't really blame the girl
all that much kids do stupid things kids
make mistakes that's like the definition
of being a kid I do blame the parents a
little bit because they didn't look into
it but again parents are gonna defend
their kids generally speaking so I don't
even blame them as my I blame the school
a little bit more mostly I blame the
culture I blame the pop culture I blame
society you candy I know I sound like a
leftist it's society man it's but it's
sort of his society here because we have
become so gullible so shallow as a
society that we eat this stuff up the
media run with it I do blame the media a
little bit the media in some ways are a
reflection of us we have a culture that
tells us believe all women you remember
during the Cavanaugh hearing that's all
you heard believe all women you say well
I want to believe credible women
and I want to disbelieve women who are
not credible
I want to disbelieve liars like we were
told we had to believe all women as
though women are a different species I
can I guess I can only speak from
experience being a man men are broken
creatures with imperfect natures who lie
and sin invariably
I guess one exception in all of history
but we'll get into that later on a
religious show women are the same thing
women are in our species they're not a
completely separate being women are
capable of lying but you're not allowed
to say that now because of feminist
culture the leftist culture in the me2
culture so we have this culture telling
us believe all women we have a culture
increasingly telling us believe all
children and there's actually a major
feminist Megan Murphy who's coming out
against this culture we'll try to get to
that a little bit later but that is what
the culture is telling us out of the
mouths of babes we need to follow
children they know so much more than
adults do and they don't they don't know
that what we have a culture that we have
this culture rather that encourages
leftist lies and excuses them until eat
until those lies are exposed and even I
guess after those lies are exposed so
the school makes this comment they say
quote we can now confirm that the
student who accused three of her
classmates of assault has acknowledged
that the allegations were false we're
grateful to the police department for
their diligent work where while we are
relieved to hear the truth and bring the
events of the past two days to a close
this is the key we also feel tremendous
pain for the victims and the hurt on
both sides of this conflict excuse me
there is no both sides to this conflict
there is a little girl who lied who was
abetted by a complicit media and then
there are the victims who were the three
little kids who were baselessly smeared
as wild bigots and maybe their parents
too it isn't oh we all have something to
be sorry for no we don't I don't even
really blame the girl I blame the media
a lot more than I blame the little girl
I mean I guess the mother should punish
her girl for lying parents should punish
their kids when they lie but kids like
kids do bad things I do blame the media
I do blame the school
I don't blame the three little kids who
were baselessly accused of being bigots
I don't I feel sorry for them and I
don't feel sorry for the people who
perpetrated this but the left always
does this they do this every time one of
their lies is exposed they'll run with
some story I mean this is a great
example of it and then it'll turn out to
be a hoax and they'll say okay so the
story wasn't true but it gets at a
greater truth okay well Duke Lacrosse
that wasn't true
the the Duke lacrosse team didn't rape
that woman but it gets it a greater
truth about rape culture
okay the jussie Smollett hoax that
wasn't true but it gets it a greater it
doesn't get it a greater truth lies
don't get it greater truths lies are
lies they're bad they should be
condemned there were victims of lies
there are victims of this dishonest
culture and guess what there are a lot
of hoaxes let's just look in just the
past year just the past year two weeks
ago edwin kaufman i don't know if i'm
even pronouncing that right he's an ex
tampabay
NFL player he trashed two of his own
restaurants he spray-painted the n-word
on the restaurant he spray-painted Magga
on the walls now he didn't do this
honestly out in the open what he said is
this was he was the victim of a vicious
racist attack he wasn't he did it
himself why did he do it
I don't know the money the attention the
fame who knows one month ago a 19 year
old guy with gender dysphoria Andrew
Smith he was in Illinois he found in a
noose in an elevator by his room and he
said that he was the victim of a hate
crime and people were coming out of him
they're coming out against him because
of his gender identity he was he planted
it there himself this came out when the
person that he tied the noose with
admitted that it was all a big hoax that
was one month ago back in June a bakery
in Ohio one in eleven million dollar
ruling against Oberlin College
why because Oberlin College that the
administrators the faculty and certainly
students there accused that bakery of
racial profiling against black students
why did they do that because three black
students had been arrested there for
attempted robbery this was a big deal
they basically shut down the bakery then
it turns out the Stu
admit that they were actually gonna rob
the store and so it was a total hoax
back in March the Southern Poverty Law
Center that absolute hate organization
came out and said that white racist
Trump supporters in Mississippi burned
down a black church and they
spray-painted all sorts of terrible
things on there and they spray-painted
vote Trump guess what happened turns out
later revealed the guy who set the fire
to the church was not a white
supremacist he was a black man and he
wasn't coming in from somewhere far away
he was a member of the church why did
they do it couldn't tell you and then of
course back in February you have Jesse
Smollett as Dave Chappelle calls him
that French actor juicy smo da jussie
Smollett who pretended that he was
attacked by two white supremacists Trump
supporters in the middle of the night on
the south side of Chicago or somewhere
in I don't remember exactly where in
Chicago well he was holding a subway
salad who gets a salad at Subway I don't
know somehow during the whole attack
with bleach and a noose and Magga hats
he didn't even drop this out nobody
nobody seriously believed the Jesse
Smollett thing when it happened well let
me rephrase that no serious person
believed the jussie Smollett thing a lot
of people seriously believed it in the
media in the left wing especially white
liberals white liberals love this kind
of stuff but serious people didn't
believe it for a second those are just
like the first five on the list this
goes on and on and on you can look there
are various websites that have indexes
of all these hate hoaxes with links to
the media reports at the time and then
links to the updates this is something
of an epidemic the left ones to pretend
that this never happens why why is the
right so much better at identifying
these hate hoaxes it's not because
racial attacks don't happen racial
attacks do happen or sexual attacks or
attacks motivated by some other kind of
bigotry they do happen they just don't
happen that much
and when they do happen you really want
to look at the details to make sure it's
it's true because who are who are the
victims of the Jessie Smollett hoax well
Trump supporters are conservatives are
half of the country are because he tried
to smear us all as racist and being a
part of a racist bigoted movement which
is not true the other victims are the
actual victims of hate crimes and
bigotry because every time there's one
of these hoaxes people take them less
seriously so who are the victims here
well certainly those three kids the
three white kids who were accused of
attacking this young black girl that
they are certainly the victims other
victims are other young black girls or
young white girls or young white boys or
any kid who is actually attacked in some
bigoted way they're the victims too
the big difference here is not how you
view race it's not how you view sex it's
not how you even view crime the big
difference why does the Left fall for it
because the left has an unrealistic view
of society and of the culture the left
always leaps on these because they think
the culture really hates women or the
culture really hates black people but
the culture really hates Hispanics or
any other racial minority group or
homosexuals or people who are confused
about their sex or any of anyone else it
doesn't
most Americans are basically good people
half of the country is not irredeemable
and deplorable like hillary clinton said
it was conservatives are better at
sussing these out because we just know
and that doesn't really happen
especially at a school if it's gonna be
Secret Service protection at it and has
pretty heightened security I just it
doesn't pass the smell test these hoaxes
happen now one conclusion of this for me
whenever I read politics I learn this
more and more it's good to cultivate
humility the more I read the more I
realize I don't know anything the more I
learn the more I realize I don't know
anything
more books I'll crack open the more I
realize I don't know very much but our
society doesn't cultivate that virtue of
humility which is the most important of
the virtues in many ways if pride is the
queen of all sins then the opposite of
pride is humility and that's an
important beginning for understanding
and for wisdom I feel this way not just
about politics or crime or any feel this
with scientific studies it's not that
I'm a science denier to use the term
that the left uses for far from it it's
actually the opposite because I do
believe in the scientific method I
believe in skepticism and I believe in
rigor and I believe that studies need to
be replicated and I believe that the
inherited wisdom of thousands and
thousands of years has been tested over
time it's not that it's old wisdom it's
that it's the newest wisdom because it
survived so much rigor over the years
and if there's some new faddish sort of
study that comes out of some university
somewhere I'm just a little skeptical of
it they do this all the time you see
this with nutrition so with nutrition
they tell you one day coffee is great
for you drink twenty cups of coffee a
day so it's really good for you then
about I don't know five hours later they
tell you coffee is gonna kill you if you
have two sips of coffee you're gonna die
and they don't just do it with coffee
they do with an egg because every other
day of the week eggs are good for you
and then the other day they're bad for
you they do the same thing with smoking
so we learned that smoking is probably
not great for you if you're inhaling all
of these things into your lungs then
we're told there's something called
secondhand smoke which is gonna kill you
if you ever walk by somebody on the
street now there's no evidence for this
whatsoever there's not a lot of rigor
around secondhand smoke doesn't matter
then we heard there's something called
third hand smoke which is if you smoke
in an apartment let's say and then you
move out of the apartment and then
someone else moves into the apartment
and they can smell it a little bit on
the carpet or something that's third
hand smoke that's gonna kill you too
pretty soon there's gonna be fourth
fifth and sixth and smoke not based in
science at all they change their mind on
these things every single day now we get
to one of my favorite ones this just
came out for years and years and years
now I have been told in part by sweet
little ELISA who cares for my health she
knows I don't treat my body very well
and she wants me to live a long time she
tells me Mac said yes sweet little ELISA
eat less red meat say no no I don't
think I'm gonna do that now her argument
is red meat is bad for you how do we
know red meat is bad for you bunch of
guys in white coats told us that for a
few years so you got to eat less red
meat I thought now first of all if I'm
gonna eat less red meat life might not
be worth living so I'm gonna do it all
so now for some reason it's irritating
the environmentalists the
environmentalists who's saying that if
you eat red meat you're destroying the
environment and they get really anxious
and worked up about this and I consider
that funny
so I guess I need two more hamburgers
and also because it tastes good and I
like it I've been pushing back on this
but the study the scientific studies
they're so clear there's no they're not
there's a new scientific study out
totally called it new scientific study
out that says there is no reason to eat
less red meat what they find is that the
evidence that was used to justify
telling individuals to eat less beef and
also to eat less pork is a weak
there's just no there's no real way to
justify that recommendation and what
they say is these findings when you find
things like this it erodes public trust
in the scientists it doesn't erode my
trust ins I know science is very
difficult and I know that the world is
very complicated and I know that
ideologue who want to tell us that they
have discovered something this the
secret the key to life if you do this
one thing your life will be perfect and
that you just that isn't true and if
scientists can't figure out red meat if
scientists can figure out the food
pyramid generally you remember when the
food pyramid said you got to eat a lot
of carbohydrates and then some fruits
and vegetables and then a little bit of
dairy and then barely any fat and then
one day about a year or two ago the
scientists came out really quietly it
was like a Friday afternoon and they
said hey hey by the way you know that
food pyramid it's the opposite all right
well we're heading out of work now so
sorry no questions no we can't yeah but
what was it it's the opposite now so
just do the opposite of the food pyramid
nobody even seemed to bat an eye they'd
say okay well the scientists say it's
the opposite now so I guess we'll follow
that I don't believe them on this one
either when I see my friends losing a
lot of weight on the key
diet I get a little nervous for them I
have a lot of friends who have lost
weight on the keto diet and they say oh
yeah keto this is like the new way to go
this is gonna give you a long life I
think you're definitely losing weight
and you look better but I don't know if
a diet that causes you to lose lots of
weight very quickly is necessarily the
healthiest diet it seems to me like for
most of human history diets that allows
you to sort of preserve your body fat
we're considered better diets anyway I'm
just saying what all of these things
bring up is that we need to have a
little skepticism we need to be a little
more aware of our faculties of reason we
need to maybe question some of our
premises if our premises keep being
proven wrong that the scientists know
everything they get everything wrong on
coffee they get it wrong on eggs they
get it wrong on red meat they get it
wrong on everything and we think that
they're going to be able to predict with
perfect certainty the weather in 100
years hmm I mean kids are taking off
school for this you've got people losing
their minds there's climate anxiety that
people are going to therapists because
of climate anxiety the scientists can't
predict the weather in a hundred years
they can't even predict the food pyramid
next week red meat is good I'm going to
enjoy some red meat tonight speaking of
the Reds we've got to get to the 70th
anniversary of Red China unfortunately I
have to takes a little issue with
President Kofi Fei he does a great job
generally but he's getting this
anniversary of the communist government
in China completely wrong then bad news
for Joe Biden again some more hoaxes on
the wage gap and so much more but first
I've got to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube you know I also want to mention
before we head out just it in the
interest of using skepticism and your
faculties of reason I want to correct
something that we said yesterday
yesterday we were covering the story of
Lupron which is the puberty blocking
drug that is used on transgender
children quote unquote is used on
children whose parents insist they have
gender dysphoria and gender confusion
and there was a report out that that
killed 63 hundred people that drug and
it's now currently being used on
children that
is true though I think I may have said
on the show yesterday that it killed 63
hundred children and that is not
accurate they killed 63 hundred people
and the drug is being used on children
but in terms of actual specifics on that
number I just don't have it so in the
interest of using our skepticism and
faculties a reason I want to bring that
up by the way another Kingdom season 3
is just days away this is the final
season of another Kingdom it is so
wonderful I don't even like novels and I
certainly don't like fantasy I love
another Kingdom and I I feel that I can
say this without any sort of false
modesty or fears about being prideful
because I narrate another Kingdom the
audiobook in the podcast but drew does
all the work drew Clavin writes the
whole thing and it is excellent and and
the first season was so good it was a
big hit when it came out season 2
also was very very successful this
season is the best one yet I know that
doesn't happen usually but it is so so
good it is profound I was reading the
audiobook of season one just a couple
months ago and I by the end of it I was
crying in the booth I mean it's just
really excellent so subscribe subscribe
today episodes 1 & 2 of season 3 drop
Monday October 7th but subscribers get
exclusive access to them this Friday
October 4th also seasons 1 & 2 if you
haven't listened to them are available
on daily wire.com iTunes and YouTube so
make sure to check those out before
embarking on this new journey which is
great you know what you get at daily
wire.com 10 bucks a month hundred
dollars for annual membership you get me
get the Andrew Clavin show you get the
Ben Shapiro show you get the Matt Walsh
show you have to ask questions of the
mailbag that's coming up so get them in
you get another Kingdom early you get
all this great stuff you get the leftist
ears tumblr you're going to need it as
more and more of their premises and
presuppositions turn out to be hoaxes
you will drown if you don't have the
template go get it daily we're calm
we'll be right back with a lot more
all right it's the 70th anniversary of
communist China President Trump tweeted
about this he said quote congratulations
to President Xi and the Chinese people
on the 70th anniversary of the People's
Republic of China I gift from slack and
a lot of things because he's doing such
a great job and he's very good at
cutting deals and I pretty much want to
give him some grace on the tweets
because he's doing so good generally
that far be it for me to throw stones
when I don't need to this was a bad
tweet there was no reason to send this
tweet I don't under if there was a
reason I certainly don't understand it
the communist takeover of China is one
of the greatest tragedies of the 20th
century possibly one of the greatest
tragedies in history it should never
have happened we could have stopped it
and we didn't after the Chinese Civil
War the but that was between the
Communists and the Nationalists the
Communists drove the Chinese Nationalist
government under Chiang kai-shek from
mainland China to Taiwan this is why the
Taiwan is such a politically volatile
issue even today that happened in 1949
the Korean War begins in June 1950 right
after that and the whole idea of the
Korean War was to set save South Korea
from falling into the invading communist
forces hands from the north so that
begins in June 1950 by December 1950
it's no longer just the Korean War you
have hundreds of thousands of Chinese
troops invading North Korea and fighting
face-to-face with American troops this
drives the US forces back to South Korea
this is a war that we were engaged in
with China at least briefly General
MacArthur wanted to take the war to
China because obviously China was
fighting a war with us he wanted to bomb
China and he wanted to fight alongside
the nationalist Chinese government
forces which were in Taiwan against the
Communists and freaking President Truman
refused he said no MacArthur said yes we
got to take care of it now we're gonna
have to take care of it later Truman
said no the conflict boiled over into
public view and in April 1951 very
famously President Truman fired General
Makar
and this is considered a great triumph
of civilian government over the military
no way had we not gone weak in Korea had
we pushed actually win the war rather
than just leave it as this stalemate
which seems to be a solution to war now
favored by many people on the left in
the United States if we had actually
pushed in one the history of the 20th
century and almost certainly the 21st
century would look radically different
Cold War would look radically different
maybe we wouldn't have gotten bogged
down in Vietnam maybe we we would have
won the Vietnam War maybe we wouldn't
have even had to fight it in the first
place and maybe 58,000 Americans and
their kids and grandkids wouldn't have
perished over there in Vietnam also an
estimated 35 to 45 million people died
as a result of the Communist revolution
in China and those are even fairly
conservative numbers all those people
would have lived and their kids and
their grandkids the Communists taker of
erver of China was one of the great
tragedies of history what is President
Trump doing congratulating them on
seventy years of communist oppression
maybe I want to keep an open mind maybe
he's trying to signal something to Kim
jong-un because Kim Drummond and North
Korea has been a key aspect of his
foreign policy such as it is maybe
President Trump is signaling an
ideological shift to Kim Jungman in
North Korea that were willing to
overlook certain abuses and we're even
over to look ideological wickedness like
communism if you come to the table and
negotiate like Trump is negotiating with
with China maybe this would be a very
blunt way to signal that you got the
President of the United States
congratulating the dictator of China on
the Communist revolution that this would
be a very blunt way to do that President
Trump is a blunt instrument in any case
we should just correct the record on
this and we should have skepticism and
to use our faculties of reason even on
our own side the legacy of communist
China is a legacy of brutality and
misery and evil it should never be
celebrated and it should always be
regretted and speaking of regrets and
Communists no that's going too far but
speaking of regrets I bet that Jo by
has a few regrets right now because you
remember we've been talking about this
giving you an update every day as new
information leaks out Fox News's Peter
Doocy asked Joe Biden about a week or
two ago whether Joe Biden had ever ever
spoken to his son about his foreign
business dealings and in no uncertain
terms Joe Biden denied ever speaking to
his son about those foreign business
affairs I've never spoken by some
overseas news news okay when that aired
when Peter Doocy was asking that
question coincidentally I was actually
on Fox and so they cut back to me right
away and said what's your reaction I
said there's no way that that's true I
don't know anything more than listening
to his response there's no way that
that's true later we found out hunter
Biden undercut the story when he spoke
to the New Yorker magazine and he
admitted that he had talked on at least
one occasion to Joe Biden about the
business dealings in Ukraine and Joe
Biden said you better know what you're
doing because obviously it sounded
pretty crooked last night Tucker Carlson
also on Fox News found a photograph
exclusively found a photograph of Joe
Biden playing golf with hunter Biden and
hunter Biden's business partner in the
Ukrainian energy company Purisima
Holdings here it is is Biden's claim
true well a photograph obtained
exclusively by this show not to brag but
we did suggest that claim might not be
true the picture shows it's on the
screen Biden on a 2014 golfing trip with
his son as well as his son Hunter's
business partner Devin Archer at the
time this picture was taken both of them
on the board of the Ukrainian energy
company Marissa
there it is there it is so you're
telling me they go out and play 18 holes
smoking cigars walking around the course
not once does their work come up not
once does the thing that unites all
three of them ever come up very
difficult for me to imagine that also
Joe Biden's stop admitting to this stuff
on film you know Joe Biden when when he
first went in and allegedly got the
prosecutor who was looking into his
son's crooked deal when he got that
prosecutor fired and then it replaced
him with a hand
successor if Joe Biden had just kept his
mouth shut about it you could understand
people get a little dodgy in politics
but he actually went to the Council on
Foreign Relations and bragged about it
on Camrys what are you doing dude same
thing here if you know that your son is
engaging in a pretty shady business
practice and trading on your name and
the power of the federal government of
the United States maybe don't smile for
photographs with your son and his
business partner in the same energy
company which is what he did Joe Biden I
mean just another reminder here by the
way it is a mistake to lie in politics
politicians lie we think of all
politicians as lying the good
politicians don't really lie I mean that
you know president Trump lies about his
crowd sizes occasionally occasionally he
exaggerated his crowd sizes
he draws pretty big crowds anyway but he
speaks like a New Yorker
he's hyperbolic so in that way he's
dishonest you'll find though on most of
the things that matter he doesn't really
lie he has this sort of refreshing
candor which actually some conservatives
get upset about sometimes because they
think he's saying too much he's tweeting
too much they say very often they wish
you would shut up Joe Biden lies he has
no regard for the truth and the reason
it's a mistake to lie in politics is not
just because it's immoral it's wrong to
do the reason is you're going to get
caught and increasingly you're going to
get caught because everything's on
camera and everything is recorded these
days it does come out in the end it
looks like it's coming out when Peter
Doocy first asked Joe Biden that
question and he told that obvious lie I
reacted to it and I said this was
obviously a lie but then the second
conclusion that you draw from that is
Joe Biden's not going to be long for
this race Joe Biden had maybe the best
shot going in of getting the nomination
if he continues to focus on this that is
going to be taken away from him the
correct answer for Joe Biden if he's
asked did you ever talk to your son
about his business dealings you say I
don't know what I've talked to my son
about he's my son and I love him sure
we've talked about a lot of things you
want to distract with this Trump
propaganda that's fine but I'm talking
about the issues that the American
people care about and then he goes back
and talks about his campaign
stump speech that's the better way to do
it then you don't get yourself in this
trap where you're backed into a corner
where obviously you're gonna be caught
in a lie and you don't get yourself in
this trap where you have to talk about a
story that is only gonna reflect
negatively on you so Joe Biden doubles
down I never talked to him about it and
you got to talk about Trump's dealings
in the Ukraine what trunk did is so
terrible in the Ukraine no get the
Ukraine out of the news when when Joe
Biden made that comment nobody knew what
was going on in Ukraine nobody knew
about Purisima holdings nobody knew that
he set up a crooked deal with his son to
get paid $600,000 a year for doing
nothing now they do is he pushed the
story big big mistake huge and they're
trying to impeach Trump over this the
more that they try to impeach Trump over
this hoax issue this total nonsense that
he colluded with Ukraine after he
colluded with Russia the the worse
that's gonna look for Joe Biden you got
that hoax you've got the hate hoaxes you
got the meat hoaxes the red meat hoaxes
and then there's one more hoax this is a
pernicious hoax that just has existed in
the popular consciousness for years
turning away from foreign policy now
turning to economics you know about the
wage gap hoax you know how this goes
this is the myth that men and women are
paid different amounts of money for the
same work which is obviously ridiculous
because if that were the case then
business owners would only hire women
unless you really think that the great
capitalists of America care more about
defending the patriarchy than they do
about making money then obviously this
thing falls apart and it's been
repeatedly debunked but it keeps coming
back why does it keep coming back
because it's true there is a wage gap
between the average woman in the average
man and then they go on and say
specifically the average Latino woman or
the average black woman or the average
and then they go down the identity
politics chart there is a wage gap it
does exist but not for the same work not
for the same educational qualifications
not for the same hours
now for the same time in the workforce
not for the same negotiated rates not
for any of that when you consider all of
those factors the wage gap virtually
disappears and actually in some places
it it exists except the women are paid
more than the men and so now the media
are in a sort of small way admitting
that this is a hoax and they're still
presenting it as a problem for women
which I just love this is headline
actually from the New York Post women
are struggling to find men who make as
much money as they do now the headline
could be women are making a ton of money
where the headline could be women are
making more money than men that'd be a
big good headline I guess but instead
because it's one of these identity
politics stories and I'm not blaming the
post everybody's doing this and it's the
way it's been framed because of identity
politics because women always have to be
the victims and they can't ever have
anything nice happen and in this leftist
view of America as being hopelessly
sexist and bigoted even when women make
more money than men the story becomes
women are struggling to find men who
make as much money as they do fair
enough based on a new study published in
the Journal of marriage and family which
is based on research from Cornell shows
that women are having trouble finding
rich guys the lead author of the study
Daniel lictor says quote there are
shortages of economically attractive men
and he says marriage is fundamentally an
economic transaction I don't know if
he's gonna have to answer to his wife
for that one and women want partners who
are at least their economic equals and
maybe they want men who make more money
than they do okay fine my only point on
this is you've got to pick a lane so you
can either keep pushing the wage gap
hoax or you can keep pushing that women
have it really rough because they can't
find men who make more money than they
do either one you can make either of
those years but you can't have them both
at the same time this is not going away
because of the the premises that people
beginning with if the premise that
you're starting with is society is bad
for women then if women don't make
enough money it's bad for women if women
make too much money that's bad for women
same thing on race same thing on sexual
identity same thing on any of these
issues maybe this means we need to
re-examine our premises maybe this means
we're looking at things just a little
bit wrong and by we I of course mean the
left brings us to impeachment which is
the big issue here right some people
really like getting into the
nitty-gritty issues of this impeachment
stuff some people really want to figure
out they're waiting for Adam shifts new
document to come out there waiting for
it just like they're waiting for the
scientific study to figure out if red
meat is good or bad for you today I
don't care I don't care about what Adam
Schiff puts out I don't care what the
Inspector General puts out frankly I
don't care about this Ukraine thing or
the impeachment inquiry they blew it the
Democrats blew it I could have cared if
it was their first shot at this or their
second shot or their third shot but it
isn't they've been doing this since day
one okay and as a result of that
faculties of skepticism faculties of
reason we've heard this song before I'm
not going to get worried about it you
know in the left if you're a leftist and
you're getting really excited for
impeachment calm down if you're a
conservative and you're getting really
worried about impeachment calm down we
have heard this song before use Buster's
compiled a supercut of the mainstream
media talking about impeachment since a
few days after President Trump was
elected here it is if he takes the risk
of going to trial he's convicted that
could be seen as an impeachable so this
is from 2016 amorous snorting cocaine in
the White House over here chance he'd be
impeached if he's not okay now we're
January 2017 there are tools that
Congress has I don't see how that
wouldn't be an impeachable offense still
in 2017 they're our and March 27
changeable offense more fully than what
bills Lawrence O'Donnell pitched for
impeachment is very difficult grab Chris
Matthews 2017 Chris Cuomo 2017 more
2017 impeachment the appropriate remedy
something through the Congress like
impeachment all of that maybe in future
this is two years ago who's that an
impeachable offense is that a
impeachable effect now we're in 2018
same story story different day where do
you see an offense it is grounds for
impeachment this is still a year ago by
the way even in P chable grounds for
impeachment or does that not go far
enough in your view grounds for
impeachment this tweet alone may be an
impeachable offense let's talk about
impeachment Pietschmann is on the table
which impeachable offenses an
impeachable offense you see okay now
we're in 2019 it's an impeachable
offense March 2019 you know what is the
President shall be removed from office
on impeachment is it impeachable a
hundred percent is impeachable this is
the one they're gonna get him this time
oh yes they're gonna I can't believe it
if you are a left winger and you're
getting so excited about this you
probably you probably put your it's
mulher time t-shirt back on you had that
one in the closet you had to dust that
one off maybe you hey you got your
stormy Daniels t-shirt remember that
remember stormy Daniels remember Michael
avenatti we're gonna forget about
Michael avenatti for the 335 years he's
facing in prison but he was a big news
story when he was around if you believe
that it could calm down skepticism
humility it'll really help you out and
this brings me to actually one of my
favorite stories will close here there's
a new US version of The Spectator which
I always enjoy reading and they
published a column today by Megan Murphy
Megan Murphy is a feminist she is the
editor of feminist Courant and she was
famously kicked off of Twitter for
saying women aren't men which is another
version of what I said men aren't women
when I got attacked by some antifoam
weirdo in Missouri this is apparently a
very controversial statement these days
Megan Murphy and I don't have a lot in
common we see the world very differently
she's a leftist and she's a feminist but
on a few issues she gets it very right
and there's a great column that I
suggest you read today it's called no I
will not listen to the children sub-line
we live in a world that tells young
people anything they feel or believe
must be validated and this is a big
issue because it incentivizes very bad
and very exploitative politic
especially on the left but it also has
us turn our faculties of reason off she
points out she writes quote I can't help
but see progressives fetishization of
youth and youth activism as self-serving
it not only elicits an emotional
reaction from people rather than a
rational one but it is used by adults as
a means to virtue signal children are
viewed is inherently moral and good and
therefore those who listen to children
and support our youth are also
positioned as inherently moral and good
listen to the children is a terrible
mantra that only exists in order to
pressure people into nodding along
unthinkingly to generally over
simplistic ideas couldn't have said it
better myself
do not allow yourself to be a victim of
that overly simplistic and unthinking
culture think for yourself and you will
be helped build and rebuild a culture
that actually values evidence reason
humility and all that is good true and
beautiful which we see eroding daily but
so much of that could come back if we
just got a little more street smart
just wised up to how people are taking
advantage of us that's our show got a
lot more to get to we'll do it tomorrow
in the meantime I'm Michael nose this is
Michael Nolt show see you then
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boy
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel why
douse key edited by danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by mike core amina hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera and our
production assistant is Nick Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 on
the Matt Walsh show we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation